everyone listen up
this is our red zone 100 square miles of
open desert with zero ground cover the
enemy will allow one vehicle only into
our red zone but we will have eyes in
the sky that means triggers off fingers
unless ordered otherwise we need to be
on our toes people
because these are some bad ass hombres
and they have come to play
why don't you just let them finger your
butthole general
mcgruber
nice of you to show up you remember your
butthole don't you it's right around the
corner from the balls and penis that
were pumping my wife last night mac this
isn't the time or the place you listen
here general
i'm kidding bud
[Laughter]
what's up gang the group are here
the general's in a committed
relationship with my ex-wife and last
night i gave them my consent
and i meant that barrett
look i'm sorry for interrupting i
believe you're at the part where you're
just about to explain why you don't just
let them finger your butthole
get it continue
thank you the attack on produce was a
highly coordinated strike using advanced
ttp and ene capabilities so it's likely
that our enemy is ex-military now the
exchange is set for o-800 uh it's uh 8
a.m o'clock eight o'clock am that's
correct anti-meridian that's uh what am
stands for
right i'd always wondered what it stood
for and so that's it you know i looked
it up
e
continue
davidson will lead fire team bravo to
the red zone where the packages will be
exchanged make no mistake people this
will be the most important rescue
mission of your lives and i want to
thank mack for his sacrifice i know it
wasn't an easy decision
you mean the decision to get killed by
terrorists and be dead forever
yes well you know
ain't nothing but a mcg thing
but that's the life we chose
death is our
job i know that every man or woman in
this goddamn room would make the same
goddamn decision that i made 11 times at
a goddamn 10.
and yeah it's brave and it's commendable
and as patriotic as [ __ ] but it's also
contagious like the clap
because bravery begets bravery
and yeah this time it's me
and next time
might be
you or you
or you
or you
or you
or you or you or you or you you get the
point
they're you
or you
or you or you or you or you you see what
i'm saying could be any one of us could
be you in the back i haven't even looked
in the back could be you in the suit you
with the thinning hair double chin
freaking frumpy dump right there it
could be you it could be anybody
but this time
it's me
this guy
please tell people i did this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you